famille amis
une trentaine de personnes se sont
réunis comme chaque année pour le
souvenir celui de leurs onze proches
disparus parmi eux marie rose bletterie
maire de christelle dont l'association
porte le nombre
c'est important qu'ils de ne pas se
sentir seul devoir avec avec le monde la
population qui est présente le soutien
pour continuer parce qu'il faut
absolument continuer et se battre pour
que tous les dossiers de l'association
soit résolu
sa fille a été tuée le 28 décembre 1996
la justice mettra dix huit ans à
identifier le coupable
finalement confondu par son adn c'est
l'un des neuf dossier des disparus de
saône et loire entre 1984 et 2005
aujourd'hui seuls deux ont été élucidés
on est à une population vieillissante on
est fatigué on a besoin d'être déjà
physique et morale est également
malheureusement financière puisque tout
un coup les enquêtes ont un coût les
astres les avocats ont un coût un combat
de longue durée soutenu aujourd'hui par
les habitants de blanc j'espère
sincèrement que ça vaut pas s'estomper
et que on va passer le flambeau que les
jeunes vont comprendre c'est ce qui
s'est passé et puis pas tomber dans le
même canton passe dans le système et
surtout qu'on n'oublie pas ne pas
oublier les victimes et les sept
familles qui attendent toujours de
savoir comment et par qui leurs proches
ont été tués